but just talk about the principles of
investing like hey guys george gammon
here i kind of know what i'm doing
here are some key elements that you
should understand number one rule is
don't try to guess which direction the
price is going
and that's what everyone does that's
that's their starting point they ask
themselves okay bitcoin or real estate
or the s p 500 is it going up or down in
price
that is unknowable right and uh stan
druckenmiller only gets it right 55 of
the time yeah so if he's getting it
right only 55 percent of the time trust
me you're not going to get it tell our
friends who stan druckenmiller he's one
of the greatest investors of all time uh
in fact his track record as a hedge fund
manager is probably the best of all time
and he's done it through multiple
decades bear markets bull markets you
name it okay so number one don't guess
what the s p is going to do or just the
price of something and that's where
everyone starts they always ask me you
know on my live streams george you know
do you think real estate is going higher
should i buy a house right now or should
i wait
you know that's a price question
instead of what you want to do is
understand that it's completely
unknowable
but what is knowable
is asking the question is it cheap
or is it expensive right so if you look
at a long-term chart of oil adjusted for
inflation you can see that when it gets
under 30 a barrel it's cheap when it
gets over 80 85 it's expensive so simply
wait until it gets cheap and buy it and
then when it gets expensive sell it
don't try to figure out the price and a
great example of this a couple in 2012
when i went uh you know head first into
real estate i actually thought the
prices were going lower but i still
bought why because it was cheap i wasn't
trying to guess the price direction and
out of that portfolio i bought in 2012 i
started selling those houses in 2018.
did i think the price was going up
probably but i sold anyway because i'm
not trying to guess the price direction
it just got expensive you see and how do
you gauge like just based on your own
sentiment about whether it's expensive
or no you just look at a chart of
an inflation adjusted chart of aggregate
real estate in the united states going
back to 1900
and it's you can find that chart simply
just google search and you can see when
it gets expensive as you can see it's
historic trend line and you know another
example was march 2020
uh when oil got it was right around 20
bucks a barrel i thought it was going to
10. i didn't get to zero at some point
there was a negative 38 okay exactly on
the futures market but i thought it
would go lower but i bought anyway
why because it was cheap
and you know i sold oil at uh probably
85 a barrel did it go higher yeah
absolutely it did but i wasn't trying
that's not the question i was trying to
answer so what you're doing there is
you're you're getting the probabilities
or you're playing to the probabilities
you've got a positive edge
so mathematically if you have an edge
the longer you employ that strategy the
higher likelihood that you actually make
money very similar blackjack uh i
started playing blackjack in the early
2000s and learned how to count cards and
it was very beneficial really in my
entrepreneurial career absolutely you're
like zach galpinakis in the hangover
just like randy i believe that i believe
i used to do that stuff but if you're
counting cards at the beginning of your
brain to think in terms of probabilities
and the you know a lot of people when i
sold when i started selling real estate
in 2018 as an example they say oh boy
you've really got to be kicking yourself
right now because you missed out on all
of those gains nothing could be further
from the truth because i played
correctly based on the probabilities you
see so the example i use in blackjack
terms it's like you're in vegas with a
buddy of yours and you know
you've had a few drinks and they're
doing shots of tequila and yada yada you
know how to play blackjack they don't
the kid gets a 19 let's say
and he's like you know what i think i'm
gonna hit because i think the dealer is
showing a tick bro and you're like you
know that's not a good idea uh just
trust me oh george you're being too
conservative what do you know oh you're
always you know trying to play with your
stupid probabilities yeah i'm going to
go ahead and hit i'm feeling lucky so
let's say they hit they get a two
yeah and they get 21 they get blackjack
did they do that i told you so george
you see that's right it's logical it's
versus emotion which obviously the
rational male we could speak on whatever
never tell me the odds but the question
is did they do the right thing or the
wrong thing and i would argue they did
the wrong thing because they have a
negative edge based on the probabilities
so if they do that continually there's a
100
chance that they go bust they will
absolutely go bust so that's how i tend
to look at investing and it would just
blow your mind the percentage of retail
investors that don't think in those
terms they think in terms of price
direction which is unknowable instead of
cheap and expensive which actually is
knowable so if you like that clip click
right here to watch another or if you
want to watch the entire saucecast click
right here
[Music]